well tennis number one novak djokovic is
facing another three nights hold up in a
detention hotel in australia as he
awaits his moment in immigration court
border officials had rejected his
coronavius medical exemption and ordered
him deported they say he can go home
anytime but back in serbia his family
have railed against his detention
this humble hotel is where superstar
novak djokovic is clinging on to his
dream of becoming the most successful
tennis player of all time
refusing to leave australia after his
stay was denied he is now sharing
accommodation with asylum seekers
in his home country serbia anger over
the treatment of a national hero has
reached fever pitch
djokovic's father gave voice to the
national grievance at a rally in front
of parliament
they want to keep him not only in
custody but in jail
[Applause]
until monday think about it until monday
they want to keep him
the best sportsman in the world in jail
at a family-owned restaurant in the
capital belgrade djokovic senior drove
home his message
they are humiliating serbia and sir
people
back in australia the government is keen
to dispel any notions of victimhood mr
jokovic is not being killed held captive
in australia he is free to leave at any
time that he chooses to do so and water
force will actually facilitate
that
the tennis star had followed regional
guidelines for an exemption to
australia's strict kovid 19 entry rules
in order to take part in the australian
open a tournament he won last year but
that exemption was denied as being valid
at the airport
an exemption by the victorian government
to play tennis in victoria
is entirely different to any exemption
or entry requirement for australia's
purposes
in the meantime djokovic is stuck in his
hotel waiting for his appeal to be heard
next week the stakes are high if he wins
this legal standoff he will get an
opportunity to win the australian open
and a record 21st grand slam
you